hi and welcome to serverless migration
station a serverless Expedition
mini-series dedicated to helping
developers modernize their apps to using
one of the latest features on one of our
serverless compute platforms today my
colleague Martin and I will hop on our
little friend part of the train to
continue our journey migrating from App
engine taskew pull tasks to Cloud Pub
sub
s great and happy to be here with now
last time in module 18 we added app
engine task queue pull tasks through the
module 1 sample app what are we doing
today
that's right Martin for those who
haven't seen the module 18 video or
completed its code lab pause here to do
so because we pick up from what module
18 leaves off today's module 19 video is
about moving those pull tasks to Cloud
Pub sub as well as migrating from App
engine and DB to Cloud NDB these and
other links are down in the description
below
now waitress uh did you say we're
migrating from App engine and the B and
app engine task use to Cloud NDB and
Cloud pops up uh isn't that two
migrations
that's right Martin modernizing means
moving off of Legacy built-in services
like NDB and tasku to Standalone
services like Cloud NAB and Pub sub
while we are doing both migrations today
we're only focused on task queue to Pub
sub because the cloud NDB migration is
covered in module 2. you also get the
option of upgrading to Python 3 or stay
on python 2 for now until you're ready
the module 19 app is python 2 and 3
compatible
that's great that people can stay on
python 2 until they're ready to upgrade
to python 3. now with regards to NDB
awaken our viewers learn more about the
module 2 migration to Cloud NDB
the module 2 video and codelab are great
resources to get familiar with that
migration we're focused on tasking
migration the rest of the way
okay
I know we added pull tasks in module 18
and caught up with that module 2
migration to Cloud NDB now how do we
migrate this app to Pub sub
the module 18 app displayed both the top
visitors as well as the most recent
visits so we're keeping the identical
functionality but switching out app
Engine Services for Standalone Cloud
products meaning end users won't notice
any difference the module 19 python 2 or
3 app will behave exactly like the
module 18 python 2 app sounds good and
now you're going to point me to the code
and the code Labs so I can do this by
hand while you're guiding us right
ah you'd think so but not yet there's
some setup we need to take care of first
uh okay uh what like what well because
we're using new cloud services they have
to be enabled first can't run any code
without doing that that makes sense so
what are we enabling and most
importantly how do we do it
well in addition to Pub sub recognize
that app engine datastore matured into
cloud datastore and the cloud NDB
libraries how python developers access
it so to use cloud datastore in Pub sub
they should both be enabled you can do
it one at a time from the cloud console
where you go to each apis page and click
the enable button like you see on the
pub sub page here or you can do it from
the command line definitely check out
the codelab which provides all the
details great I was able to enable both
services and what else do I have to do
before we update the sample app
well next we have to get a good
understanding of how the terminology
changes when switching from task queue
pull tasks to Cloud Pub sub with task
queue data goes into pull cues with Pub
sub data goes into topics
task queue pull tasks are called
messages in Pub sub
with task queue workers access pull
tasks with Pub sub subscribers receive
messages
leasing a pull task is the same as
pulling a message from a pub sub topic
via subscription
deleting a task from a pull queue when
you're done is analogous to
acknowledging a pub sub message does
that all make sense yeah that was really
useful overview Wes and I really like
that table you showed us now that I know
this is there any more setup we need to
do
yes per the chart we just covered we
need a topic and a subscriber in order
for our app to work there are three ways
to creating these resources from the
cloud console on the command line or
with code using the pub sub API that's a
lot of options with uh which one are we
using
well good question Martin well it's
pretty straightforward to do it in the
cloud console there are separate dialogs
for creating topics and subscriptions
but you know I prefer the terminal so I
would do it with this pair of command
line commands the last option is to do
it from code using the pub sub API the
module 19 repo has a sample python
script called maker.py that does it here
you see it's got separate functions for
creating each resource we've provided a
link in case you want to check it out
all that's useful I picked one and now I
have both a topic and a subscription can
we code yet
for sure here and below are links to the
repo and codelab we'll start with the
module 18 code and finish with what's in
the module 19 folder pause if you need
to hit find your module 18 code or copy
it from the repo okay ready let's go to
the computer and do this migration for
each migration let's ensure we're
starting with a working app in this case
the module 18 sample go to the folder
where your code is and delete the lib
folder if you have one run the PIP
install command to install the
third-party libraries into lib python 2
developers know self-bundling like this
is required by app engine and one big
benefit to upgrading to Python 3 is that
you no longer have to do this now deploy
to the cloud with gcloud app deploy the
app should show the top visitors and the
most recent visits now that we have a
working app we can replace its use of
pull tests with Cloud Pub sub
Nexus configuration the first step is
straightforward the q.yaml file is to
create our pull queue since we're moving
from task queue to Pub sub there's no
need for it so delete it the module 18
requirements.txt file is listed only
with flask we're migrating to Cloud NDB
and Pub sub so add those client
libraries here too next is app.yaml what
we do with app.yaml differs depending on
whether we stay on python 2 or upgrade
to python 3. let's start with python 2
adding use of cloud client libraries
requires two built-in libraries setup
Tools in grpcio these are already
available for you on app engine servers
so all you do is add or update the
library section to list them with a
preferred version or latest for the
latest available if you're porting the
sample app to Python 3 you're removing
stuff delete everything except for the
runtime directive changing it to a
supported Python 3 version say 310. see
the code lab for more details on these
updates to app.yaml for app Engine
config.py things also differ between
Python 2 and 3 for Python 3 it's easy
just delete it because it's not used and
there's no other third-party package
requirement except for listing them in
requirements.txt for python 2 we need to
add a few lines to support setup tools
and grpcio built-in libraries that we
just added to app.yaml a minute ago
that's it for config if you're staying
on python 2 delete the lib folder and
rerun the PIP install command to
repopulate it with flask in the cloud
client libraries Python 3 users don't
have to do this as they'll be installed
automatically during deploy now let's
look at the main application
starting at the top replace the Imports
of app engine ADB and tasky with Cloud
NDB and Pub sub most of the constants
stay the same perhaps with Pub sub name
changes but add another constant for the
worker
using Cloud client libraries requires
API clients so instantiate those clients
for cloud NDB and Pub sub right after
flask pubsup itself needs additional
resources for topics and subscriptions
for example publisher and subscriber
clients those have different path names
and each require the project ID so get
that from Google off default why this
extra work while Cloud NDB and pubs of
our separate products so that's why
there's more setup realize that you can
access them with non-appigen apps
creating new visits querying the most
recent visits counting visitors and
querying top visitors doesn't really
change the only difference is due to
Cloud NAB requiring use of its python
context manager when making data store
calls so you'll see new with blocks
encapsulating those calls in store visit
fetch visits and fetch counts
the other change is also small but
probably the most impactful and that's
where we replace adding a new pull task
with publishing a new message to a pub
sub Topic in store visit
the worker function log visitors sees a
good number of changes both versions
grab the work that's to be done and
extracts the visitor bumping up the
corresponding Vis account the pub sub
version does a bit more work in that it
also has to track acknowledgment IDs
because that's how you confirm the work
is done while pull tasks are directly
deleted once all the counts are in we're
done with Pub sub so act the messages
then update the visitor accounts and
data store there are no changes to the
root Handler wrapping up the changes now
let's confirm that the new module 19 app
works ensure that you've enabled Cloud
datastorm pops up as well as created a
pub sub topic and subscription python 2
users should delete the lib folder and
repopulate it with a pip install command
if you haven't already done so
when ready run gcloud app deploy then
hit your app on App engine you should
see the top visitors followed by The
Familiar most recent visits just like in
module 18. now that looks great but
recall from module 18 that the visit you
just created isn't part of the overall
visitor account yet there's a message in
the pub sub topic waiting for a worker
to pull if you can visit your app a few
more times from different computers to
get a good number of messages in the
topic again you won't see any change in
the app other than the most recent
visits now let's run the worker you can
use a browser but it's easiest to do a
curl or wget command in a terminal
regardless of which you use hit the
slash log endpoint and see the results
showing how many visitors were logged
the next time you visit the app in a
browser you'll see an updated top
visitors list along with the most recent
visits that's it now let's go back to
the main presentation wow that was a
pretty big update with Pub sub looks
like an interesting product and we only
tapped one of its features
can you point me to its documentation
including migrating app engine pull
tasks to Pub sub
well certainly link below is the
migration guide to Pub sub I've also
linked to the python 2 pull tasks
overview in case you need that the pub
sub docs overall and finally a link to
accessing bundle services like task
queue and Python 3 in case you want to
Port your app to Python 3 first before
migrating your pull test to Pub sub
that was a lot of useful documentation
to check out
now that we successfully migrated pull
tasks to Pub sub what other migrations
should I consider
great question and a couple come to mind
before this migration we added pull
tests which was covered last time in
module 18. don't forget app engine also
has push tests which we migrated to
Cloud class and that's covered in module
789 we also migrate from App engine NDB
to Cloud NDB here so review module 2 for
more details we couldn't cover today if
your app uses app engine memcache
consider migraine in Cloud memory store
that's covered in modules 12 and 13. if
your app uses app engine blob store
consider migrating to cloud storage and
see modules 15 and 16. if you want to
upgrade to Python 3 but stay using App
engine bundle Services see module 17
those running small app engine apps or
those who want to break up large
monoliths can consider Cloud functions
covered in module 11. finally if your
containerization is now part of your
software development workflow you can
migrate to Cloud run module 4 is for
Docker users while module 5 is for those
who are new to Containers or don't want
to do Docker Docker files or even think
about containers and we look forward to
having you join us on any of these
Journey this is Wesley on behalf of
Martin and Porter and we'll see you on
another serverless Expedition soon in
the meantime happy travels
[Music]